est revenue
une grande famille quelques jeunes et
beaucoup d'aînés ils ont rendez-vous
avec leur père le plus grand le tout
puissant
un rendez vous avec dieu pour lui
adressé des louanges
des prières et des témoignages des
chrétiens venus pour se confesser et
être exhorté
depuis lundi ils sont entre 900 et 1000
à suivre un programme d'encouragement
collectifs et individuels wild et les
personnes à avancer dans leur propre vie
eh bien il ya des fois on peut faire des
puits en particulière où les aider s'ils
en difficultés intérieures
voilà qu'ils ont quelque chose qu'ils
ont vécu un traumatisme une blessure
intérieure en pin ou re trois jours
intenses animé en partie par une petite
délégation de la côte d'ivoire
et
[Musique]
j -c l'est sud est et ce thème blessures
et guérison longuement développé par ce
prédicateur a provoqué des réactions
spectaculaire des cris et des trans un
pauvre cri le seigneur en temps et
aujourd'hui nous concluons en invitant
les gens à accueillir le don de l'esprit
pour partager à notre tour c'est un mot
aux autres parce qu'on n'est pas aimé
que pour nous même nom mais en vue de
transmettre cet amour aux autres
se conserve c'est vraiment la
représentation de dieu sur cet esprit ça
donne des délivrances des délibérations
je pense en fait que la martinique a
besoin a besoin aux yeux c'est un jour
de gloire certains jours on a la
possibilité de tout lâcher
c'est un jour où le seigneur est vivant
ce séminaire toujours aussi populaire
est organisé chaque année depuis onze
ans